de l'intimidation sur les chantiers
c'était le sujet aujourd'hui à la
commission charbonneau qui reprenait ses
travaux rejoint isabelle donc isabelle
c'est un enquêteur de la commission qui
est venu témoigner il a fait le tour des
chantiers de la province et décrit bon
j'allais dire terrorisme syndicats c'est
peut-être exagéré mais décrit un climat
de peur en particulier sur la côte nord
oui alors c'est tant qu'à terme ciel
comme ou se promener avec son équipe a
mal partout et il en rapporte un
portrait assez peu reluisant sur les
chantiers des à bulles qui ont été qui
leur ont été racontées des entrepreneurs
force et d'embaucher des travailleurs
d'une allégeance syndicale donner des
travailleurs qui sont celui de ralentir
la cadence parce qu'ils travaillent trop
vite sur les chantiers des entrepreneurs
à qui on extorquent de l'argent pour
assurer une paix syndicale on paye
littéralement en argent comptant pour
avoir prédit sûr d'avoir la paix sur les
chantiers et même surintendant qui a été
menacée parce qu'il avait osé s'adresser
à des syndiqués et il ya le nom de
bernard rambo gothique on a vu le sont
les images qui est souvent revenu
écoutez bien et l'extrait suivant fait
qu'il ya beaucoup de menaces j'ai eu
beaucoup d'heures seulement ils nous
racontent qu'ils se promenaient il
circulait à wavre saint pierre et du
puits elle est jeune je suivais un pick
up et avec son véhicule puis il voulait
le faire sortir de la routine et que tu
arrives à quelques occasions
il raconte que lorsqu'il a voulu en
parler à des patrouilleurs de l'aed là
est ce qu
que c'est à bernard rambo 5 ans qu'il
est une idée et une giclée policiers
craignaient même ses représentants
locaux et par ailleurs hydro québec a
fermé les yeux fermé les yeux sur pas
mal d'abus justement way pour avoir la
paix effectivement sur le chantier de la
centrale hydroélectrique péribonka ya
quelques années il y avait une firme
allemande bawer qui avait amené ses
travailleurs ils ont été obligés de
quitter de rentrer en allemagne il ya
que les groupes six sont restés mais en
vertu d'une entente avec la ftq
construction ils ont été jumelés avec
des grutiers du québec qui ont été payés
pendant deux ans à rien
douze travailleurs des grutiers qui
étaient payés
à rien faire soit dans des vans près des
délégués rue des arts 2 soit dormir de
nuit ou de jour à jouer aux cartes ou à
plaques auteuil ou dans des roulottes à
dormir aller au bout des choses comme ça
vous accueillez payé par hydro-québec ou
pays prépare heures facturées donc avec
pareille payé par power plus les
factures hydro québec alors des exemples
comme cela de vandalisme d'intimidation
de menaces patres on entendu toute la
journée il ya bien peu de gens
disponibles pour venir les raconter
devant la commission mais quand même il
semble que deux entrepreneurs qui seront
entendues en personne une histoire de
moteurs également aussi qu'ils faisaient
de la vente de billets de loterie alors
une autre forme de d'extorsion sur les
chantiers gardel garde l argent là le
mari s'est pas trop salée bon merci
isabelle ans on suit ça de me recevoir